enduring the obstacles of war
indignity in death
this is life in mariopol now
i hope there will be some sort of a
reburial and this is just temporary the
military told us to put the bodies
somewhere in the cold the only cold
place now are basements but there are
people in basements so we bury them here
it is difficult to see how life can go
on for people in a place like this
the blockade of mario paul will go down
in history of responsibility for war
crimes
to do this to a peaceful city what the
occupiers did it is terror that will be
remembered for centuries to come
more are escaping war every day but
getting to safety can mean risking your
life
active conflict zones russian
checkpoints ukrainians say it's
difficult to know which way is safe
and not everybody makes it
they began to destroy our city
completely house after house battles
took place on every street every house
became a target
mariopol's residents fled a city still
under russian attack
from la viv a plea to end the war
dear russians we ask you all to go home
deal with your own families you have
entered someone else's land someone
else's territory you are not liberating
you are barbarians we hope that you all
leave and never disturb anyone ever
again
at the largest reception center in
levive volunteers prepare for an influx
of evacuees from the war zone
thousands have come and gone thousands
more expected in coming days
one family from a village near kiev said
the worst part of their journey was
witnessing the horrors of war
[Music]
we were passing through a russian
checkpoint
and saw a lot of bodies lying near the
road some of them were shot some missing
body parts
at one checkpoint in the village we were
waiting for two buses that were part of
our convoy but they were all gunned down
by pro-russian forces at another village
pro-russian chechen fighters hold people
hostage they say
knowing ukrainian military will not
shoot at civilians
what can i say she says i'm scared a lot
i don't want to leave
they are safe for now
together
warm
happy
but once his family is in poland
vladislav says he will go back to fight
zayn basravi al-jazeera levi